South Korea's new president wants to
improve ties with North Korea moon
jae-in says he wants to reach out after
relations worsen over recent North
Korean missile launches potential
conflict threatens the security of
millions of South Koreans along with
American troops and their families in
the country nor O'Donnell is in Seoul
South Korea where she will interview the
country's present tomorrow it will be
his first American broadcast TV
interview since being elected nor good
morning hey good morning or Anya haseo
as they say here in South Korea here's
what's really interesting president moon
was just elected last month he's going
to the White House next week what he's
doing is talking about reigniting the
sunshine policy he wants to have
dialogue with the north he said he wants
to sit knee to knee head-to-head with
Kim jong-un to have talks he says he's
willing to negotiate without
preconditions he wants the north to
freeze their nuclear program and what's
really making waves back home in the
State Department is one of president
moons top advisors saying that they'd be
willing to scale down joint u.s. and
South Korean military exercises which of
course has been sort of a staple for
many years here in South Korea so a lot
of change is at foot charlie and that's
why it's really interesting to be here
at this time because as you know the
defense secretary general mattis has
said that North Korea is a clear and
present danger to all it is the greatest
national security threat that faces the
Trump administration nor a lot of people
might not realize that there's a bit of
a homecoming for you spend a lot of time
in South Korea is a child so how things
change there for you since then that's
right my dad was in the army so I
actually lived on Yongsan army garrison
which is home to more than 20,000 US
troops and actually if you think about
Yongsan which is here in Seoul and the
distance between the base and the DMZ
it's just about the distance between
Washington Nationals Park and Camden
Yards in Baltimore I mean that's how
close they are and that's how dangerous
this situation is which makes this new
president what he plans to do all the
more interesting to cover and we'll have
that interview tomorrow on the show
Nora Donald thank you very much from
Seoul and nor will bring us her
interview with South Korean president
moon Jana she mentions tomorrow right
here on CBS this morning